premier tour des élections législatives
marquées par un nombre de voix
historique pour le rassemblement
national je tiens d'abord à exprimer
toute notre gratitude et a remercié les
4 millions 250 mille français qui se
sont portés sur les candidats de notre
mouvement
le résultat d'hier contredit largement
sondages et commentaires médiatiques
avec 208 second tour soit près du double
qu'en 2017 le rn progresse d'un million
deux cent soixante mille voix et se
retrouve en capacité de l'emporter dans
plusieurs dizaines de circonscriptions y
compris en guadeloupe ouvrant à minima
la voie à la multiplication par cinq du
nombre de nos députés ainsi qu'à la
constitution d'un groupe puissant à
l'assemblée nationale fait je le rappel
inédit depuis 1986 cette progression
constante du rassemblement national
confirme l'enracinement durable de notre
famille politique dans tout le
territoire et apparaît comme une
nouvelle étape de notre objectif
inchangé de conquête du pouvoir je le
dis cette percée fait du rassemblement
national la seule force politique en
dynamique
emmanuel macron apparaît affaibli sans
garantie d'une majorité absolue est en
recul de 6 points par rapport à 2010 est
malgré le mensonge la complaisance et
l'enthousiasmé médiatique en faveur de
jean-luc mélenchon celui ci n'a comme
nous l'avions dit et répété aucune
chance d'être désigné premier ministre
cette fable prend donc fin est le
discours de vérité comme de lucidité de
marine le pen qui lui avait pourtant été
reproché correspondait là encore à la
réalité la droiture la cohérence et le
discours de vérité sont indissociables
de notre engagement pour la france et
les français le bloc de gauche et
d'extrême gauche recule lui aussi d'un
point et demi par rapport à 2010 est sa
prétendue percée triomphante et là
encore un mensonge qui doit être dénoncé
et dit aux français le bloc de gauche et
d'extrême gauche n'est pas l'opposant
emmanuel macron et sa béquille soutien
de monsieur mélenchon et de tous ses
amis à emmanuel macron au second tour de
la présidentielle
elle est aujourd'hui remercié par celui
de plusieurs membres du gouvernement qui
appelle à leur tour à voter pour
l'extrême gauche face au candidat au
pluriel du camp national
en clair je te soutiens la
présidentielle et tu me soutiens à la
législatif en renvoi d'ascenseur qui en
dit long on ne peut pas être un opposant
conséquent et crédible au président de
la république en l'ayant fait élire et
en appelant à voter pour lui au second
tour de l'élection présidentielle
ma chronique et extrême gauche s'oppose
artificiellement mais appartiennent tous
deux au camp des déconstructeurs l'un
veut livrer la france aux prédateurs
d'en haut et en faire une salle de
marché les autres veulent la livrer aux
prédateurs dans bach et en faire une
gigantesque zad regroupant les
idéologies les plus destructrices pardon
et les plus dangereuses pour la france
dans soixante et une circonscription les
français ont la possibilité de faire
barrage à un candidat du ps à la
coalition burqini constitué d'islamo
gauchistes le militant anti flics et
pyromane communautariste en se
choisissant un député est reine qui
défendra à leur pouvoir d'achat leur
mode de vie et la valeur travail
dont 106 circonscriptions les français
ont la possibilité de faire battre un
candidat macro nist demain à l'assemblée
votre à la retraite à 65 ans l'explosion
de la fiscalité la submersion migratoire
et le chaos sécuritaire qui ont
découlent pour se choisir un député est
reine qui défendra la baisse pérenne de
la fiscalité sur l'énergie la priorité
nationale au logement et à l'emploi le
rétablissement de frontières qui compte
qui protège et le rétablissement de
l'autorité de l'état pour tous et
partout
l'enjeu du vote de dimanche prochain est
double conjurer le spectre d'une
majorité absolue pour emmanuel macron et
faire rentrer le plus grand nombre
d'avocats du peuple à l'assemblée
je veux ce matin lancé un appel à la
mobilisation
à tous les français à tous les électeurs
de marine le pen du rassemblement
national et plus largement à tous les
patriotes attachés à la défense de la
nation je vous appelle une nouvelle fois
à vous rendre aux urnes le dimanche
emmanuel macron n'attend qu'une seule
chose votre abstention à ce second
alors confirmé confirmer et amplifier
votre vote donnez-nous de la force pour
vous protéger et vous défendre durant
cinq ans face au saccage social au
matraquage fiscal face au désordre et à
la submersion migratoire que s'apprête à
poursuivre emmanuel macron lui laissait
pas les pleins pouvoirs et saisissez
cette ultime chance dans six jours de
lui faire barrage
contre la république traoré d'un côté et
la république mckinsey de l'autre nous
sommes les garants de la république
française défenseur du pouvoir d'achat
et de la valeur travail notre identité
nationale la laïcité du retour de
l'ordre et de l'autorité face à une
situation migratoire et sécuritaire
aujourd'hui hors de contrôle dans une
démarche
d'union nationale et de rassemblement
des français
j'appelle les électeurs d'eric zemmour
et les patriotes sincères de l air à
faire barrage à la macro ni et à
l'extrême gauche à donner de la force à
leurs idées à travailler avec nous et à
nous rejoindre en utilisant ce dimanche
des bulletins de vote rassemblement
national
les bulletins de vote rm seront partout
où nous sommes qualifiés au second tour
un acte de résistance face à toutes les
forces de déconstruction
dix-huit départements de france nous
serons face nous serons présents
au second tour dans toutes les
circonscriptions des grands chelems sont
possibles les surprises auront lieu et
contribueront je le crois à oxygéner
notre démocratie avec ces députés qui
entreront au parlement
le rn compte faire émerger une nouvelle
élite pour le pays qui contribuera par
son travail son implication à
l'assemblée comme sa proximité avec le
peuple français à réconcilier nos
concitoyens avec la politique à l'envers
de ce que nous avons constaté ces cinq
dernières années ils ne seront pas des
députés hors sol mais des élus du peuple
enraciné dans la vie quotidienne des
français capable d'être demain et après
demain les piliers d'une alternance dont
notre pays a tant besoin nous sommes
donc enthousiastes
combatif et déterminé pour ces 6 ultimes
jours de campagne nous aurons l'occasion
de nous voir cette semaine puisque
marine le pen et - aviron soutenir ses
futurs députés partout en france sur le
terrain dans les heures qui viennent
voilà ce que je souhaitais vous dire ce
matin je vous remercie et je suis à
votre disposition pour répondre à vos
interrogations
[Musique]